you
hello everyone welcome to today's live
broadcast next generation icp-oes and
edie x RF instruments plus better
analytical techniques equals improved
laboratory profitability I'm julissa
murasa blabbers and I'll be your
moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by laborat
the leading scientific social networking
website and provider of virtual agents
and webinars advancing scientific
collaboration and learning this webinar
is sponsored by spectro petrol is one of
the worldwide leading suppliers of
analytical instruments employing optical
emission art spark so es icp-oes and
x-ray fluorescence spectrometry XRF
technology used for the elemental
analysis of materials in industry
research in academia spectro is a member
of the Ametek materials analysis
division before we start there are a few
instructions we want to hear from you
during this interactive broadcast so
please ask questions or leave us a
comment
answers are welcome to you can do this
by hitting the green Q&A button at the
lower left of the presentation window
and typing in your comments and
questions we'll try to get to as many as
we can and we'll follow up if we don't
have time today want a better look you
can enlarge the slide window by clicking
on the screen icon in the lower right
hand corner of the slide window if you
kick or see the presentation properly
let us know by clicking on the support
button on the top right or use the Q&A
button well make sure we try to resolve
any issues this is an educational
webinar and does offers free continuing
education credits after the webinar is
over please click on the CD button
located in the bottom left hand corner
of your webpage and follow the process
of obtaining your credit now let's get
to today's presenters we are proud to
welcome
Olaf Schultz and Dirk Guzman Bo Schultz
is the product manager for icp-oes and
is responsible for strategic development
of the
product line including application
development and product support Olaf's
experience in optical emission
spectroscopy for materials analysis and
testing spans more than 30 years with an
engineering degree in physics he started
his career in the auto industry
initially at Robert Bosch and Zenit
Porsche Olaf's moves to spectro in 1989
with assignments and application
development sales and marketing Dirk is
a product manager for XRF instruments
and is responsible for the strategic
development of the complete product line
including application development and
product support Dirk's experience in
spectroscopy began with his graduate
work in physics at the University of
Eagan there he worked with Fourier
transform spectrometry in the UV
invisible range in combination with
inductively coupled plasma dirk moves to
spectro in 1990 with assignments and
quality control training application
development and marketing please join me
in welcoming Olaf and Dirk
well thank you very much Julie today I
would like to talk about how using
modern instrument technology the
productivity of elemental analysis can
be improved and this really covers
almost all components of the instrument
for the icp-oes this is how selecting
the right plasma orientation can make it
a lot easier and reduce maintenance how
latest solid-state technology avoids
idle times and helps to analyze more
samples today how money can be saved by
intelligent interface and optic design
and how a sample deduction can be
optimized while high sensitivity speed
and thus the capability for automation
are clear advantages of the ICP
technique modern edx RF has caught up
substantially in terms of sensitivity
with little to no sample preparation and
ease of use a stronger role in the
future for environmental analytical
tasks can be predicted my colleague dear
Chrisman has the details about the
latest developments Laboratories operate
in a competitive market because of a
title control of the environment and
items we consume elemental analytical
and sample numbers have steadily
increased
however with public budgets under
permanent pressure not only method
performance and the fulfilment of
regulations and QC requirements the
quality of the analysis are paramount
but efficiency cost and speed are
likewise important for economic reasons
as a tool for elemental analysis icp-oes
are the instruments of choice for this
kind of work since they provide the
sensitivity required for the
determination of trace metals the
question is how using modern
technologies time can be saved whether
the application of high performance
equipment can make the use of additional
techniques obsolete how samples example
times can be reduced and instrument
operating costs can be minimized trying
to find an answer to those questions
there are is a principle one to be
answered first which plasma orientation
is the best for my application
although various attempts have been made
over the last thirty years today to
plasmic viewing directions and plasma
torch orientations have prevailed radial
and axial horizontal and the vertical
torch design now actual plasma
observation has the advantage that the
entire central channels viewed which
improves the sensitivity for most of the
elements by about a factor of three for
the alkali and the earth alkali elements
improvement factors are even greater
than 10
however this technology also suffers
from stronger influences since the
entire channel is visible all phenomena
present in the excitation zone including
the plasma tail and bottom are within
the light path the most relevant effects
are recombination signal depression self
absorption and the easy ionizable
element effect also for high amounts of
totally dissolved solids and organic
solutions the horizontal alignment of
the plasma torch is not the optimal
design since deposits are most more
likely to form viewing the plasma
radially the central channel is only
sampled partially and while this
provides a generally low sensitivity the
cool top as well as the plasma bottom
are blanked out and thus matrix effects
are gradually reduced in addition with
the vertical orientation of the plasma
torch and the interface being arranged
in a right angle to the plasma deposits
inside the torch and on the interface
are less likely to form therefore the
radio observation technique is typically
chosen in the case of total dissolved
solids concentration in the axis of 10%
for routine analysis of organic
solutions or where high stability and
precision are required now the table
here on this slide shows the sensitivity
comparison between the axial and the
radial observation technique as
explained the axial observation improves
the sensitivity for most elements by
about a factor of 3 to 4 however this is
not true for matrices with an increase
of the plasma load the sensitivity
decreases to effect off
point five to two in for example a 10%
sodium chloride matrix and even to a
factor of 0.7 in kerosene so does that
mean that the radio observation
technique is in fact the superior
technique well no this is not quite the
case also in a heavier matrix even
though the increase since is much
smaller axle observation has the
potential to provide a somewhat higher
sensitivity particularly for alkali
elements so if ultimately if ultimate
sensitivity counts the choice could be
axial even though the application is
otherwise better mastered using the
radial technique but even with higher
TDS concentrations a true radial plasma
instrument can safely be used for
routine analytical work a horizontal
torch design with higher TDS is not
quite so easy to use since it requires
more attention and more maintenance the
slide shows a practical example for the
analysis of trace elements in a pure
copper matrix limits of detection were
determined using radial and axial plasma
observation with a 2% solution
horizontal axial plasma torch works
routinely without any problems certainly
higher TDS concentrations are possible
but this is where attention and also
regular maintenance is needed this is
possible but as this occupies personnel
probably it's not the best and the most
efficient way running the same
application using a vertical radial
torch the same application can easily
use vector to lower dilution as
mentioned earlier alkali elements would
still somehow show an improved
sensitivity compared to the radial
technique but for this example those are
not required and so it enjoys the same
for some elements and even better
sensitivity when comparing limits of
detection in the salt material and it is
much easier to use obviously it is not
only the observation technique which
enables the introduction of higher
metric samples into the plasma but the
plasma generator also plays a very
important role it
robustness needs to be achieved by
design and today this is made possible
using latest solid-state technology with
the advent of high-power LD Mo's
transistors indeed a new era of ICP
generators has begun those transistors
feature extreme current density with
excellent heat dissipation and they are
also short circuit proof these
generators are extremely agile do not
require any mechanical network and have
almost the identical characteristics of
a freerunning types tube system they're
therefore considerably more powerful and
robust our game assistants do not
contain any consumable parts which
reduces maintenance and repair and makes
them particularly suitable in the case
of high availability requirements and
last but not least they are also very
efficient particularly that it does not
require any extremely cooling system
makes it a big money saver the slide
here shows the capability of such a
system in terms of plasma load it can
bear even gasoline in a one-to-one
dilution with kerosene can critically
aspirate it at room temperature without
extinguishing the plasma the for
stability test at a concentration level
of 500 micrograms per kilogram
demonstrates that such loads are
suitable for routine use without any
problems another advantage of those new
LD moe systems is their short-term
stability gradient as the graph shows
using a 95 to 105 criteria to judge
stability even for emission lines in the
UV like an iminium at 167 Ana meters and
phosphorous at 177 nanometers a stable
state is achieved within 10 minutes
compared to conventional generators this
means for most applications the work may
start 20 minutes earlier so in addition
to saving the costs for argon this is
about 500 euros every year and electric
power assuming and analysis time of 90
seconds per sample 3,500 additional
samples can be analyzed each year
however the biggest saving really comes
from the apps
of a cooling system spectra ICPs do not
require any external water cooling in
addition to the oscillator and the Lord
coil now also the interface is fully air
cooled by the spectral spi for radio
plasma observation did never require any
cooling now also the OPI air requires no
cooling it consists of cooling fins
which surrounds the actual interface and
by a directed flow of air through the
fins the interface is effectively caught
this saves not only the purchase costs
of a relevant cooling system as well as
the costs for electricity and
maintenance and avoids breakdowns but
also means less noise and less heat in
the laboratory
now the purchase cost of a cooling
system may certainly very locally and
also depend on size but if we assume a
price of around about 4,000 uly4
thousand euros and life expectancy of
four years and eight hours operation per
day annual costs of around about 1,500
euros can be saved let's continue with
the optical system and I want to talk
about the different types today but
concentrate on the passion loaner
optical design but everybody who is
interested there's a special on-demand
webcast available about the subject
through our resource center now except
for spectral partial owner optical
systems are not the most commonly used
for ICTs however they are by far the
most popular used for optical emission
spectrometers and there's a reason for
this plasma optical systems use a
concave refraction grating and light is
dispersed but the image of the entrance
slit is also focused on a circular path
provided all optical components are
mounted on a circle and the focal length
of the grating equal to the diameter of
the circle now this enables fully
simultaneous detection over a wide
wavelength range as the system does not
require any transmission optical
components also the UV and the via via
specular ranges are accessible a main
characteristic is that the resolution is
rather uniform
over a wide spectral range now today
this design has been further enhanced
the enhanced design is called the
optimized Rowland circle alignment or
Orca and this has been introduced 2005
here all components are mounted on an
optic body made from two aluminum cast
shells this merges the optical bench and
the optical chamber a new one and
enables an extremely small volume and
also the possibility for direct thermal
stabilization as one can see here on the
cut image which shows the top lid off
individual detectors
units are mounted above and below the
focal curve in a continuous fashion
cursed as stereo mirrors are used to
image the relevant part of the spectrum
onto the photosensitive array of the
detector and so the design allows for
simultaneous detection maximum
wavelength coverage including the UV and
vov specular range while maintaining
highest sensitivity and resolution over
the entire wavelength range so how does
this technology help to improve
productivity now let's start with the
access to the UV and the v UV spectral
range first this requires the right
spectrometer design since any
transmission through quartz glass
absorbs radiation below 160 nanometers
more transparent glasses made from
magnesium fluoride needs to be used for
the UV and the vov range this is to
avoid transmission optical components as
far as possible since also reflections
reduce the amount of light by about 15%
or reflection the overall number of
optical components is likewise important
another aspect is that which is common
to see CDs as well as CMAs detectors is
that they're not very sensitive in this
wavelength range and need to be treated
with a virgin coating in order to
measure this kind of light any of the
Aqua design has a distinct advantage
with no transmission optical components
inside the optic and only few optical
components in general this concept
provides
i transmission in this spectral range
and moreover the use of multiple
detectors makes it easy to install units
optimized for the task about not only
the optical components but also the
molecular oxygen and water vapor in the
atmosphere heavily absorbs radiation
below 180 nanometers so the entire life
path needs to be free from oxygen and
water in the past this was commonly
achieved by evacuation of the optical
system and purging of the interface and
transfer optic using Ireland for Boston
also contamination reasons this
technique was abandoned however to purge
the optical system also only works to
about 160 nanometers below this
wavelength remaining pockets of air and
water vapor cannot be really effectively
replaced by the inert gas anymore to
solve this dilemma and provide an optic
chamber free from atmospheric oxygen and
water as well as oil vapor contaminating
one UV plus was developed about 15 years
ago here vacuum proof chamber as he
decorated and then filled with argon to
atmospheric pressure to the chamber
purifying circuit consisting of a
membrane pump and an absorber cartridges
connected so any ingress of oxygen and
water is in this way effectively
eliminated this thing is most effective
and provides really excellent
transparency in the wavelength range be
low 190 nanometers the life expectancy
lifetime of the cartridges to use no
gases consumed and the optical system is
permanently ready for use also possible
damage of the optical components through
contaminated gas is impossible well the
table here on this slide shows the
overall saving which uv+ enables
compared to a perched optical system
local costs for argon gas may vary but
in this example assuming 8 hours of
operation per day 3 liters per minute
purged during operation and one
liter per minute purchased that by UV
personally save up to 3000 euros per
year now the other criteria of optical
concept is certainly speed the graphic
you see on this slide shows the
comparison between a sequential and a
simultaneous approach measuring element
by element and replicate by replicate
much more time is spent compared to a
fully simultaneous capture of the
spectrum which all spectral ICPs do from
a source spectrum the required
information is simply extracted and
since this can be done at any later
point in time results can be reprocessed
even new elements and lines the Edit
even long after the analysis took place
now even though attempt has we made in
recent years to try to reduce the argon
consumption and flows of 10 liters per
minute are possible for certain
applications ICP is in general consume a
lot of expensive argon at a total flow
rate of 15 point 4 liters per minute and
it should be noted that really all gas
flows are not only the plasma gases are
considered and in case of a 90 second
analysis time and costs of 70 euros for
bottle of argon the gas costs per
analysis amount to 11 cents rinsing
between samples requires additional time
and so annual costs for argon can be
several thousand euros for this reason
the faster the analysis can be done the
better compared to sequential system
simultaneous I cities in principle enjoy
an advantage the more elements need to
be analyzed
since the costs remain the same
independent from the number of elements
to be analyzed in addition much higher
number of samples can be processed per
day while a sequential ICPs at 17
elements per sample may analyze about
140 samples per eight hours
simultaneous icp-oes independent from
the number of elements may handle up to
320 samples in the same period
but what else can be done to reduce the
annales time well until the sample
finally reaches the plasma it needs to
travel some distance
therefore sample still remains in the
tubes even after the analysis is
finished only after it has been
completely replaced with new sample the
next analysis may start intelligent move
is a technique which uses the remaining
sample solution in the tubes to step to
the next sample or the rinse position
before the actual measurement has ended
and so depending on the length of the
tube from the sample probe to the
nevelocity 15 to 20 seconds can be saved
with each analysis compared to a normal
sequential procedure where a rinse or a
new sample measurement is only started
after the completion of the current
measurement rinsing is another procedure
where time may be saved while the rinse
in the in between sample measurement is
crucial to prevent carryover and
guarantee accurate analytical results it
is also when the instrument is most
unproductive this is particularly
problematic with environmental
applications where white concentration
ranges and larger concentration changes
from sample to sample make further
rinsing important now intelligent rinse
is a flexible approach where not only a
rinse time is used but the time required
is determined by a concentration
threshold value set for each element
during the rinse the concentration are
constantly monitored as soon as all
concentrations are below a defined
threshold limit the rinse is stopped and
the autosampler proceeds to the next
sample so in cases where sample
concentrations are low only little time
is spent for the rinse and only in the
case of higher concentration maximum
time is used to rinse in order to
guarantee accurate results
also by using a different technique to
deliver the sample to the introduction
system time that can be saved a standard
icp-oes uses a single peristaltic pump
to deliver samples to the nebulizer and
rinse the fluid path after the analysis
in contrast a load coil switch valve
system like the CTA s Express utilizes a
vacuum pump a six port valve and a
sample load call in addition both pumps
can be used simultaneously so Samba can
be loaded into the coil while the sample
path through the nebulizer is rinsed now
this helps to reduce total sample
analysis time quite significantly the
vacuum pump rapidly fills the sample
call Luke while the peristaltic pump
simultaneously delivers solvent to the
nebulizer to maintain stable conditions
in the plasma the Dalton switches the
ports and sample is then transported to
the net eliezer for analysis using the
solvent via the peristaltic pump
simultaneously the autosampler probe is
moved to the rinse station and the
update flow path is flushed with rinse
solution via the vacuum pump so compared
to the standard sample uptake using a
peristaltic pump time is saved since the
distance between the sample and the
sample nebulizers only a few centimeters
this compares to a up to 1 meter long
fluid path needed to transport a sample
from the furthest corner of the
autosampler via the autosampler probe
the capillary tube the pump tube and
another capillary tube to the some
production system also rinsing the
system time is saved since the pump tube
does not get in contact with sample at
all the wetted surface of the sample
coil is rather small and the sample
transfer path of simultaneously cleaned
during analysis the saving is much
smaller however since still the wetted
surface of the spray chamber is a lot
larger and thus ultimately determines
the rinse time required we just set the
setup for an environmental application
using the combination of the ASA Express
and intelligent rinse and with this the
sample uptake and stabilization time
could be reduced from 60 seconds and
that included
a 20-second fast pre flush to 24 seconds
for samples with trace concentrations
the sample to sample terms for to
replicate readings we could so P reduce
240 seconds using sister setup it should
be noted that it adds a certain
complexity to the analytical process
however the correct timing relies on
defined volumes and so the tube sizes
and lengths are important and they must
be kept constant when maintaining the
system fair missus summarize I believe I
was able to explain that using
state-of-the-art methods and
technologies the productivity of icp-oes
elemental analysis can be improved but
in all cases axial plasma observation
provides the best results running
samples in a lower dilution using radio
plasma observation and vertical torch
design similar sometimes even better
sensitivities are achieved while time is
saved otherwise required for maintenance
robots LD Mo's generator technology
enables the introduction of high matrix
and volatile samples into the plasma and
has extremely low stabilization times
which saves consumable gases and
increase the sample throughput with the
absence of an external cooling device
annual costs in the range of 1000 500
years can be saved without the
requirements to purge the optical system
UV plus saves up to 3000 euros every
year so even without a further reduction
of the sample to sample times those two
techniques alone may save a good portion
of the instruments purchase price over
its lifetime to see how further
optimizing the sample measurement
process effects cost the calculator you
can see on this slide is also available
in the IC POS section of our website
please try it out ok with a sign at the
end of my part of this talk I thank you
very much for your attention the second
part will be covered by degrees bun
senior product manager for the EDX RF
product line we'll continue with the
latest developments in the field of
x-ray fluorescence technology well
thanks Olaf thanks for the nice
introduction so after the detailed
explanation
the ICP let's change the topic now
energy dispersive x-ray fluorescence
spectrometry is one of the elemental
analysis techniques which is changed
dramatically over the last years
different types of analyzers are
available from handheld through portable
to lab instruments each of them suitable
for various applications so my part of
the presentation I will go a little bit
through the sample preparation that is
required for x-rays I will demonstrate
what is the right analyzer for your
application now we'll do that with some
examples in the use of analysis of soil
and characterization of waste using
x-rays and also from the analysis of air
filter materials so when we look at the
sample preparation we also can look at
available test methods that describe not
only the analysis technique x-ray
fluorescence spectrometry but they also
explain a little bit about what is
required in terms of sample preparation
so for example you can look at the ISO
18 to 27 oil quality determination of
elemental composition by x-ray
fluorescence it also gives some guidance
on sample preparation the same is true
for the European norm for the en 15 3:09
characterization of waste and soil
determination of elemental composition
by x-ray fluorescence in the US and also
is definitely it's - then for liquid or
semi-liquid samples there are two more
test methods from ASTM that describe
also the preparation of samples before
x-ray analysis is done so we look at the
flow chart is described for example in
the ISO 18 to 27 and the en 15 309 for
the analysis of soil sediment fly ash
and sludge well it all starts from the
laboratory sample so in this case we're
not talking about sample taking sample
homogeneity and so on but we start with
the sampler as it arrives in the lab
first step that typically included here
is then the drying of the sample and
then already the first decision has to
be done the first question is is a
qualitative analysis required or is a
quantitative analysis required well
typically a qualitative analysis will be
more a kind of a yes/no decision is this
element above the certain limit is it
below a certain limit well that can be
done probably already in many cases from
a course loose powder depending on the
application but if more accuracy is
required then the next step included is
milling of the sample is higher accuracy
required okay then you probably have to
go take the next step and prepare a
press pellet or depending on the element
of interest you have to prepare a few
speed if the screening analysis is the
only goal of the analytical tasks then
the analysis can be done based on the
fine loose powder so you see not only
important that we know what l of water
elemental analyzer typical but it's also
important to know what is the goal of
the analysis now let's go through the
different analyzers because you can
imagine well not all of them are equally
well suited for all of the applications
so in many cases already with the
selection of the analytical tasks the
required sample preparation the IDI XR s
and ELISA should be selected the same
way for a quick on-site check nobody
would expect accurate analysis for major
elements in the soil or sediment sample
and the handheld XRF instrument is
always needed application with different
characteristics portable or laboratory
instruments will be the right choice so
you can see here three images of
instruments from spectral to handheld
spectral XO to support the portable
spectral scout and the lab instrument or
spectrum z boss so what can you expect
from a handheld XRF in
well in principle the setup of any EDX
RF instrument is fairly easy the
excitation of the element is done by by
an x-ray tube the connection of the
fluorescence radiation is done typically
by a semiconductor detector what is
different is the performance well not
all of the instruments are equipped with
the same components if the attention
limit in the range of 5 to 10 ppm are
sufficient for trace elements and the
accuracy of major elements is not that
important
and held x-ray instrument will be
perfectly suited as you can also see
from the analysis result of a soil
reference samples which is shown here if
better performance is required a
portable EDX ref instrument might be the
right choice so in this case we're
talking about the spectral Scouter
portable eye xref instrument which is
designed really for on-site use as well
it includes a 4 watt x-ray tube and the
silicon drift detector with high
resolution and high count rate
capabilities in contrast to most our
handheld instrument this instrument also
can be optionally equipped with the
helium purge or with the vacuum system
so that you have access to elements and
the lower atomic numbers that are not
accessible when the instrument operates
in the air so when we're looking again
at the sample that is prepared as a
powder in an x-ray our sample cup well
in this case we're not talking about a
coarse powder now we're talking about a
fine powder so a little bit of sample
preparation may be already required in
field the measurement time now is also
pipe a longer compared to a typical
analysis time used for a handheld XRF
instrument here we start with say maybe
three to five minutes but also you can
analyze the sample for 10 to 20 minutes
when we look at the results here well if
we would go back to the original results
for example using a hand
instrument then you could see that they
analyzed value as for some elements
closer to the certified value but what
is even more important is that also the
statistical error of a single analysis
is much lower well that's first
depending on the longer measurement one
one nobody wants to hold the handheld
instrument for that noncom measuring
time and also it is depending then on
the sensitivity of the instrument so see
that will be typical results using a
portable EDX raft system based on new
developments in instrument hardware
significant benefits for users of EDX
rack instrumentation can be achieved
where in the past
EDX ref was seen more as a screening
tool now it's correct rised by high
sensitivity and low detection limits and
with this the scope of the usage is
expanded even further than ever before
so what you can see here is the
schematic diagram of a spectral sepals
edx or as laboratory instrument so
what's different here compared to
previous generations of this instrument
is also here we're using now the latest
detector technology with large area high
current rate and high resolution and
what's also new and this instrument is
the adaptive excitation so we use a
polarizer and band pass filter in
combination whereas specifical x-ray
tube for the excitation so if we compare
the limits of detection of such an
instrument in a pure silicate matrix to
for example the spectral code listed
here as other edx raf instrument then
you can see that there is a significant
difference especially in certain areas
of the periodic table so you see the
major benefit then for the elements from
sodium chlorine to chlorine then also in
the range between potassium and
manganese and also for higher atomic
numbers
like palladium silver cadmium tin
antimony tellurium and so on so this is
achieved by the polarizer by the
bandpass filter and by an excitation
using 60 kV excitation voltage compared
to the standard 50 KB for example in
spectral Scout so you can see the
benefits in the building individually
pointed out from the polarizer that is
true then for the elements from sodium
to chlorine then we are using a thick
anode binary alloy x-ray tube with a
cobalt excitation and in combination
with a bandpass filter you can see that
there is a dramatic improvement for the
detection limits and the range between
potassium and manganese and as I said
before the benefits from using a 60 kV
excitation are clearly visible and
that's especially important for
environmentally critical elements like
cadmium for example so what kind of
analysis results can you expect from
such an instrument to see compared to
the list that I had shown for the
handheld instrument and also for the
portable instrument now the list of
elements is even longer here we can see
the analysis results for the example of
a metal rich sediment the s dar - m2
sample and you can see that again
compared to the portable EDX or F
instrument the spectral Scout here at
the errors of the analysis is lower
again or that's based on the higher
sensitivity of the instrument and that
we also get very good precision very low
statistically are all for the major
elements as well so typically those
samples are still alum analyzed as
powders or are analyzed as pressed
powder pellets so that's typically done
for soil sediments and geological
samples
if on the other hand the focus is also
to achieve high accuracy for the major
elements then X or F well that's been
commonly known to x-ray as specialists
is suffering from so-called grain size
and mineralogical effects so nobody
would do a real accurate analysis of an
exit example based on a on a powder
sample for limited applications press
pellets can be used but if you have
larger concentration changes in your
samples then those samples are typically
prepared as you speak so maybe you can
remember back what was shown on the flow
chart of the two international test
methods so what is given here is then
two correlation Russ one for sodium
oxide infuse beads with a very good
correlation and one for the correlation
of iron oxide infuse beads with also a
very good correlation that means if the
samples are prepared in a proper way
then we can determine major elements
with a high accuracy what you can see on
the table here is analysis result based
on that type of calibration for a
geological reference sample from France
for the anodes it ang sample and for all
of the results we had good agreement
between the certified and the analysed
value as one last example again from the
environmental field I just want to show
you a little bit about the analysis of
air filters will ambient air monitoring
that's a typical task for ICP
instruments but also a typical task for
EDX or F instrumentations and certainly
one major argument for EDX ref is that
this analysis is non-destructive
and is also very fast because no
additional sample preparation is
required in this case what you can see
here on the right hand side is a table
with detection limits that can be
achieved yells when we're looking at
directly to filter material
in nano grams per square centimeters or
as limits of detection in air in nano
grams per cubic meter both than in three
Sigma limits the detection limits that
are obtained here were calculated based
on measurements or filters with a
diameter of 40 millimeters and in case
of them calculation for limits of
detection in air estimating a sampling
of 20 cubic meters air on one filter so
again you can see that we have very low
detection limits here and one element
that is certainly all the interest
especially for ambient air monitoring is
the element cadmium where we can achieve
a very good detection limit of only 2.4
nano grams per cubic meter air so this
is one additional application example
for the x-ray DXF and with this I come
to the end of my part of the
presentation as well and I hope that all
of and myself that we have shown you
that extra narration icp-oes and edx RF
instruments just better analysis
technique lead to improve the berkeley
profitability for more information you
can else check our website as all of
already mentioned there are some more
documents available there you will find
application notes white papers you will
find the cost calculator for the ICP if
you have any specific questions well you
can raise that question now or you also
can send L solar for me and email if any
questions come on later on thanks
excellent presentations Oh awesome
Derrick dirt thanks for bringing that
information to us before we get started
with all your questions
here's a quick reminder about how to
reach us today questions can be sent via
the green Q&A button at the lower left
of the presentation window we'll get to
as many of them as we can if we are
unable to get to your question today we
we'll follow up via email so let's get
started our first question is Olaf you
mentioned that this new generator you
are using it has a standby mode which
runs nine liters per minute of argon is
lower than normal flow also usable at
higher plasma powers well let me say
that depends and that ultimately depends
a bit on the samples you're analyzing as
long as the sample is relatively clean
one can run a plasma with lower flows of
argon round about you know 10 to 11
liters per minute and as soon as the
totally dissolved salt concentration
goes up in the sample or once I have an
organic matrix this is not really
possible any more or let's put it in a
different way you can still try to do
this but this will shorten the torch
life quite considerably so it's
something which needs to be calculated
do I want to save some add on and spend
more time in torches because the torch
life will be a lot shorter or do I spend
a bit more time with more money in argon
use higher flows but then my torches
lasts a bit longer great Thank You Dirk
which technique would you recommend for
a lab which analyzes more than 100
samples per day well again that also
depends on the analysis task yeah mm it
is tasks for example for for a soil
analysis is only the screening on of the
soil for metals and heavy metal
concentration then for example a
handheld instrument will do then also a
portable instrument will do and also the
spectral Depot's will do an outstanding
job although it must be mentioned if you
really want to go down too low detection
limits then typically in a lab that runs
100 samples or more per day then ICP
instruments are used but you also have
to keep in my
always that you also then have to manage
the sample preparation for that high
amount of samples okay thank you
Olaf does air cooling reply require any
extraction to outside the lab well let's
say it's recommended because it is it's
obviously warm air and this is very much
the same as using a external cooling
system which is placed in the lab also
that dissipates heat into the lab and
that's also something which is not quite
desired because it heats up the room so
you also want to you know place it
outside the laboratory and the same
applies where this air which comes out
of the instrument it is it is warm and
so it's obviously best if you extract it
to the outside however if the room is
large enough or you have an air
condition and you are able to to keep
the temperature in the laboratory
relatively constant you know round about
20-25 Celsius then this is also not a
problem to do because what comes out of
the generator is really nothing but warm
air obviously I mean the front part the
plasma requires an extraction because
the plasma gases they need to be
extracted to the outside thank you
Dirk
the analysis results using ICP and XRF
always comparable where are the
differences or impact on the results not
always comparable if you for example
look at some of the certificates that
are available for reference samples then
you in some cases will find different
two different result one result is then
for as a complete idea digestion of the
sample and another set of results may be
then given for a typical at Borodino
digestion in that case for example the
element chromium and the certified
concentration for chromium may be
different that may affect other elements
as well so I would say in many cases you
will get comparable results but there
are cases where it really depends
especially on the sample preparation and
in this case I would say for the sound
in the sample preparation for the ICP
analysis whether you get the same
results or not so some of the elements
are influenced by this great Thank You
Olaf can I change the purifier for the
optic myself yes there's not a problem
that is fairly easy it uses its
self-locking fast connectors so you just
need to disengage them take the
cartridge out put a new cartridge on
lock them again and that's it but it
most likely will not be required the the
cartridge has a guaranteed lifetime of
two years and typically within a two
year lifetime there will be some kind of
maintenance on the on the instrument so
so typically this is something which is
replaced when when an instrument
maintenance is done in any case ray
thank you Dirk
how important is sample preparation for
each of the techniques
can both express them as I mentioned and
that was visible from the flowchart of
the of the test methods already it
depends on what the analytical task is
typically you would dry a sample you
would pulverize the sample and then you
would analyze the sample as a powder in
cup or you would analyze the sample as a
pressed pellet then as mentioned for
high accuracy analysis of light elements
of major elements in an oxide example
you would prepare a few speed so it
really depends on what the analysis task
is for the ICP well.all of maybe you
want to add some comment to that as well
what is typical sample preparation
depending on the sample dilution or
digestion I mean for environmental
samples very very often the samples are
digested even even though they are air
liquid Thank You Olaf you said that
vertical torch ICPs have benefits higher
salt concentrations compared to the
horizontal design what about the
vertical do love you wouldn't that be
the best combination hey well well we
think so and well one thing is certainly
true it's a it is a vertical torch and
the vertical torch definitely already
saves the dilemma that the horizontal
design is not so comfortable with high
amounts of totally dissolved solids and
also organic solutions but one was also
not forget is that still let's say an
axial interface is involved and this
axial interface in case of a vertical
torch rests on top of the plasma still
and and so there is still contamination
happening obviously and and not only
that most likely because we have this
contamination there is also a certain
probability that
in point of time the contamination which
rests on the interface gets back into
the plasma so also one has to think of
company contamination of the optical
surfaces and certainly also the thermal
stress onto that component is rather
high
once the interface is placed on top of
the plasma so I'm not so sure whether
this is really really a good solution or
little a good design and it's all one
portion but it it doesn't solve let's
say the it doesn't solve the problem
completely so still a true vertical
torch design is definitely the preferred
way when having higher amounts of total
dissolved solids and organic solutions
Thank You Dirk what is the operating
cost of an XRF instrument well in terms
of the operating cost we we certainly
have to distinguish two different parts
one is the cost that is involved when
handing the samples so for some of the
applications that I show there is the
analysis is done directly from loose
power in a sample cup so it would mean
for each of the samples you would have
to have one sample cup and then you also
need some x-ray transparent film to
close the cup so that you can do the
analysis so depending on the cup that
you're using and depending on the film
type that you're using this might be
around one dollar per sample maybe a
little more maybe a little less so
that's the basic cost for powder
analysis in addition then if you would
analyze a sample as a press pellet then
able to add some cost for the binder you
need to press then also to prepare a
press pivot and also a dye to press the
pollutant for a fused speed analysis
then you would need a flock so you would
need the flux and you may need an L
select electricity or some gas to
operate the flux ax but as all belongs
to
kind of sample handling and sample
preparation in terms of operating the
x-ray instrument well all of the x-ray
instruments that I am shown that I've
shown today are energy dispersive x-ray
instrument so the smaller six ray tube
can be found in the handheld instrument
then as I mentioned in the portable
instrument with four watt x-ray tube and
in the lab instrument we have an x-ray
tube operating at 51 so electricity is
not really a huge amount of cost what is
an additional operating cost that that
has to be spent as then if you are
really interested in the analysis of
light elements because then you also
have to purge the system has to purge
the area between excitation sample and
detector with helium or you have to
evacuate it or if it's evacuated
then again the vacuum system just adds a
little bit of electric electricity cause
if it's the helium purge that is
required for example in terms of or when
analyzing liquid or powder samples then
this is fairly low maybe only four four
and a half liters of helium per sample
in addition then long-term running costs
operating costs for the instrument
because as in any X or F instrument well
in principle the x-ray tube for example
is the long-term consumable so you have
to consider that you have to replace the
tube after that's a typically several
years of operation and the same has to
be applied for the detector but this is
this is not very often that you have to
replace it but this is the type of
overall cost that you have to look at
thank you we'll wrap up with one last
question and that for Olaf can a switch
valve system be used with any spectral
ICP yes this is not a problem we do not
use integrated systems but they are
external and so first of all they can be
used by any of our ICPs and any ICP is
also upgradable at any later point in
time
so one can decide later
this technology is needed yes or no
right I would like to once again thank
Olaf and Derrick for their presentations
do you have any final comments
well thanks again for hosting the
webinar and also thanks to the audience
or for their interest in today's topic
yeah also thank you very much from my
side I think this was a very interested
webcast and well should you have any
questions I mean please feel free and to
ask we will certainly answer them than
by email I would like to again thank our
speakers all s Schultz in dirty salon
today as well as our sponsor spectro for
making it possible to bring this
presentation to you today's webcast will
be available for on-demand viewing
through December 8 2017 you will receive
an email from us alerting you when it's
available on demand and posted on lab
routes comm you are welcome to forward
this announcement to any colleagues who
weren't able to join us today thanks for
logging on and participating in today's
broadcast see you next time bye